Okay, Jason, all right. Should I sell on a site that will go dry during the winter? It has leads coming in. Yeah, Jason, you can do, you guys can sell, you know, you guys can still do deals. I talked about this last week, winter's coming.
You guys have a couple of really, really good weeks. There's going to be a slow period from like December 15th to the end of the year, because it's, it's not only cold, but it's the holidays and everyone gets weird.
But then on January 1st, everyone's magically motivated. But up until about mid December, it's a phenomenal time to get deals because everyone's, you know, things are starting to things are starting to cool off.
And I don't just mean with the with the weather. I mean, with business, dude, it's like, it's that time of year where things start to cool down and people like, shoot, I got Christmas coming up, I got to make some money.
Little Johnny wants that freaking little, that little bike, a little e-bike, that little motorcycle at 50 cc that's actually electric, they can buzz the school. So you can be like all the other kids and we keep with the Joneses. That's what people are going into right now, dude.
Okay.
So, yes, what you got to be careful of and you got to make sure of Jason and go rewatch the training. If this isn't clear, set expectations. Okay, don't oversell it, let them know, hey, you know, this is this is, we can get this thing going for you.
And as you know, it's going to be the slowest time of year. So the good thing is, you know, going forward, it's not going to get any lower. It's going to be better from here. But you know how December is, right, dude. I mean, it's just it's winter, right? You just have you just don't oversell it. You got to you got to frame it correctly. You got to make sure that the business owner is aware that it may be a little slow. But to them, it might not be slow because they have nothing to compare it to. Right. They never worked with you before. But yeah, absolutely, guys. I am never, you know, there's some people that are out there that are like,
you know, I don't do you know, during these months, I've met business owners, you guys will meet business owners like this, right? Like, let's say they're in concrete. I knew this guy was in I think it was concrete. And he told me he's like, look, I'll buy your leads until December or whatever. And he's like, then what I do is I literally leave my state, whatever he was at. And I moved to Florida for December and January and February. It's like, I don't kick pick back up until March. Okay. And guys, I
think there's something to be said there if you need it. And that's the best time to take it off. But for those of us that don't give a shit about taking time off, and we're out to go and take over the world, and we want to go as big as possible, we want to go and shake things up, and we want to see how big we can take this, then I'm a big believer that you're always do deals. Okay, I'm a big believer that you're always buying real estate, I'm a big believer that you're always, you know, you're just moving forward, you're not an idiot. But you're always
doing deals, and you're not going to try and time it perfectly. When I launched this program, I launched it on at the worst time of year, on probably one of the worst days I could have launched it, everyone I talked to said, you know, don't launch it on a holiday, because people are going to be out with their families not going to be sitting by a computer, no one's going to show up to your pitch. And don't do it like during the winter, because dude, that's going to be the slowest time of year. Guess what I did, I launched this bitch, I literally announced it the night before, thanks
giving 2021. And I launched it on Black Monday, right? Couldn't have been and they also say don't do it on Mondays. And I debated I said, man, maybe I should wait till February, March. You know, then this is my justification for not taking action like well as we spring, it'd be easier to get deals.
And I was like, no, no, hell no. We're going to run this on, you know, whatever next week, whenever I decided this, I'm like, and I'm going to do it because it's now's the time. Okay. So I'm always doing deals, I don't try and time it perfectly, try and time it perfectly, you're going to lose, okay, you try and time the deal perfectly, because you know, the business owner didn't sound like whatever, you're going to lose deals, okay. Now, is there a situation where you get on the phone, the business owners partners not on? Yes, maybe you reschedule there. But I know people who they get into
a deal, and everything is good to go. Maybe, you know, whatever happened, the business owner doesn't have this or doesn't have that or they whatever they're at a job site, and they told them not to be sometimes you just got to send it, dude, most of the time, you just got to send it. And I believe it evens out, I would rather go for it and have that mentality of like full send every single time. You're going to win in the long run. Okay, so Jason, yes, set expectations, don't be afraid to do deals, it's a great time to do deals, have the mentality that deals happen in the winter, and it's a great time you're going to get deals.
Okay.